you see you were reading the character
of hang style oh yeah yeah I know that
well we kind of saw you more for Tommy
Hank sir stoner buddy Tommy yeah sure
that's coach Jay and Silent Bob it's
been a while and I can't believe you are
still some matter little boy blue it's
nothing it's today was the additional
isn't it they just wanted you to be Jay
right just want to be taken serious for
Jay and silly bill are over drop some
method on it that's it read this book
I'm gonna text you the name of this book
I talked to your mind about the method
acting book once you read the book you
can't honor eat it that case oh I don't
even know and you can't read the book
dude and it is taking my crap that a
whole other level
[Music]
you think this tree was gonna offer you
the lead and an Oscar hopeful be careful
Jason what are you not telling us mr.
Mia call the studio Jay but they're
going in a different direction they're
trying to sabotage my career Jason is
more my friend than he is yours
they're desperate bullet pierce me Jason
Holly quiz live as I breathe you're like
my best friend in the world but you are
not a leading man Jason Mewes that
smoochy boochi guy boy heard he's a
knucklehead I nail it my career
surpasses yours one more son that better
not be trouble in paradise
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you